IN SEPTEMBER OF 2022 OUR
OFFICE OF STUDENT AFFAIRS
REPORTED TO THE
MULTI-DISCIPLINARY THREAT
ASSESSMENT TEAM THAT MR. JONES,
THEY RECEIVED INFORMATION THAT
MR. JONES HAD MADE A COMMENT
ABOUT POSSESSING A GUN TO A
PERSON THAT WAS UNAFFILIATED
WITH THE UNIVERSITY.
IN OTHER WORDS, A THIRD PARTY.
THAT REPORTING PERSON, AGAIN
UNAFFILIATED WITH THE
UNIVERSITY, TO BEST OF OUR
KNOWLEDGE NEVER SAW THE GUN.
THE COMMENT ABOUT MR. JONES
OWNING A GUN WAS NOT MADE IN
CONJUNCTION WITH ANY THREATS.
THE OFFICE OF STUDENT AFFAIRS
FOLLOWED UP WITH THE REPORTING
PERSON AND MADE EFFORTS TO
CONTACT MR. JONES.
IN FACT, THEY FOLLOWED UP WITH
MR. JONES ROOMMATE WHO DID NOT
REPORT SEEING THE PRESENCE OF A
WEAPON.
PARDON ME.
>> THANK YOU, CAPTAIN.
WE JUST RECEIVED INFORMATION
THAT THE SUSPECT IS IN
CUSTODY.
JUST GIVING A MOMENT TO THANK
GOD.
BREATHE A SIGH OF RELIEF.
MR. JONES ALSO HAD COME TO THE
ATTENTION OF OUR THREAT
ASSESSMENT TEAM BECAUSE HE WAS
INVOLVED IN A -- A HAZING
INVESTIGATION OF SOME SORT.
I DON'T KNOW THE FACTS AND
CIRCUMSTANCES OF THAT
INVESTIGATION.
I KNOW THAT IT WAS EVENTUALLY
CLOSED DUE TO WITNESSES THAT
WOULD NOT COOPERATE WITH THE
PROCESS.
BUT THROUGH THE COURSE OF THE
THREAT ASSESSMENT TEAM'S
INVESTIGATION WE LEARNED OF A
PRIOR CRIMINAL INCIDENT
INVOLVING A CONCEALED WEAPON
INCIDENT THAT OCCURRED OUTSIDE
OF THE CITY OF CHARLOTTESVILLE
IN FEBRUARY OF 2021.
WHAT IS INTERESTING ABOUT THIS
CASE IS HE'S REQUIRED AS A
STUDENT AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
VIRGINIA TO REPORT THAT AND HE
NEVER DID.
AND SO THE UNIVERSITY HAS TAKEN
APPROPRIATE ADMINISTRATIVE
CHARGES THROUGH THE UNIVERSITY'S
JUDICIARY COUNCIL AND THAT
MATTER IS STILL PENDING
ADJUDICATION.
I THOUGHT IT WAS IMPORTANT TO
SHARE THAT INFORMATION WITH YOU.
TO LET YOU KNOW THAT HE HAD BEEN
CALLED TO OUR ATTENTION AND TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE ABOUT THAT.
I WANT YOU TO HEAR THAT.
I WANT YOU TO HEAR THAT FROM ME.
NOT HEAR IT FROM SOMEONE ELSE.
SO I'LL STOP THERE AND WE'LL
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MIGHT HAVE.
>> WE HAVE TIME FOR A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS.
>> CAN YOU DISCUSS WHAT -- WHERE
THEY ARE GOING, WHAT IS THE
AFFILIATION OF THE PEOPLE THAT
WERE ON THAT BUS AND ON THAT
TRIP AND IF THE SUSPECT WAS PART
OF THAT TRIP OR STEPPED OFF OF
THE BUS?
>> THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION.
THE INFORMATION WE HAVE AT THIS
TIME THAT THE FIELD TRIP WAS
ASSOCIATED WITH A CLASS AND THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE BEEN NAMED
WERE PART OF THAT TRIP TO SEE A
PLAY.
THAT IS TO SEE A PLAY ASSOCIATED
WITH THE CLASS.
SO IT WAS A CLASS FIELD TRIP.
>> WAS THE SUSPECT IN THAT
CLASS?
>> I DO NOT HAVE THOSE DETAILS.
>> DO YOU KNOW WHAT CLASS IT
WAS?
>> I DO NOT.
>> DO YOU KNOW WHAT THE PLAY IT
WAS.
>> I DO NOT.
WE'RE SEEKING OUT ALL OF THAT
INFORMATION AS YOU COULD
IMAGINE, THE STUDENTS ARE QUITE
TRAUMATIZED BY THE TRAGIC
EVENTS.
>> I DO NOT HAVE THE EXACT
LOCATION.
WE'LL FINALIZING ALL OF THAT.
>> SO THE PLAY WAS IN
WASHINGTON, D.C.?
>> I HAVE NOT BEEN -- SHARED
THAT INFORMATION YET AND IT WILL
COME A POINT IN TIME WHEN WE
WILL SHARE THAT INFORMATION BUT
NOW IS NOT THE MOST APPROPRIATE
TIME.
>> [ INAUDIBLE QUESTION ].
>> WE'RE NOT RELEASING
INFORMATION ABOUT THE PATIENTS
WHO ARE STILL IN THE HOSPITAL AT
THIS TIME.
>> [ INAUDIBLE QUESTION ].
>> I CAN'T SPEAK FOR STUDENT
AFFAIRS.
THE UNIVERSITY OF POLICE
DEPARTMENT HAD NO CONTACT WITH
THIS.
THE UNIVERSITY OF POLICE
DEPARTMENT IS ONE OF MANY PEOPLE
ON THE MULTI-DISCIPLINARY THREAT
ASSESSMENT TEAM AND WE PROVIDE
SOME OF THE BACKGROUND WITH
RESPECT TO INDIVIDUALS TO COME
BEFORE THAT TEAM BUT TO MY
KNOWLEDGE WE DO NOT HAVE ANY
CONTACT WITH MR. JONES WITH
REGARD TO THAT INCIDENT.
>> [ INAUDIBLE QUESTION ].
>> MY UNDERSTANDING IS ABOUT
BALLPARK 25.
DON'T KNOW HOW HE GOT AWAY OR HE
FLED THE SCENE AND I DON'T HAVE
INFORMATION AS TO HOW HE WAS
APPREHENDED.
>> [ INAUDIBLE QUESTION ].
>> WE'RE IN THE PROCESS OF DOING
THAT NOW.
>> [ INAUDIBLE QUESTION ].
>> NOT AT THIS TIME.
>> WHEN AND WHERE DID THE THIRD
VICTIM DIE?
IT SAID TWO WERE FOUND DEAD ON
THE BUS.
>> THIRD VICTIM WAS TRANSPORTED
TO THE MEDICAL CENTER AND DIED
THERE.
>> JUST A COUPLE OF MORE.
DO WE KNOW MR. JONES STATUS.
AT ONE POINT HE WAS ON THE THE
FOOTBALL TEAM.
HE WAS STILL A STUDENT HERE AS
OF THIS MORNING.
WAS HE STILL AFFILIATED WITH THE
FOOTBALL TEAM?
>> HE WAS STILL A STUDENT BUT TO
MY KNOWLEDGE HE WAS NO LONGER ON
THE FOOTBALL TEAM AND HADN'T
BEEN ON THE TEAM FOR OVER A
YEAR.
>> ARE YOU ABLE TO --
>> THE TWO OTHER VICTIMS WERE
STUDENTS.
>> DO YOU THE POLICE KNOW AT ALL
THE SUSPECT PRIOR TO THIS?
WAS THERE ANY RELATIONSHIP?
>> I DON'T KNOW TO WHAT EXTENT
THEY HAVE A RELATIONSHIP WITH
HIM.
I DON'T KNOW THAT FOR SURE.
>> YOU PERSONALLY HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED WITH SO MANY TRAGEDIES
IN YOUR TIME HERE IN
CHARLOTTESVILLE.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU'VE BEEN ABLE
TO PROCESS THIS COMMUNITY OVER
THE PAST DECADE AND HOW THIS
IMPACTED ALL OF IT.
>> I DON'T KNOW THAT I BARELY
HAD TIME TO PROCESS THAT TO THE
EXTENT THAT YOU SPEAK OF.
COY TELL YOU THAT THE PEOPLE
STANDING BEHIND ME NOW, IT
SPEAKS FOR ITSELF.
HOW WE GET THROUGH THESE THINGS,
THESE AGENCIES THAT ARE
REPRESENTED HERE WERE ON THE
GROUNDS VERY QUICKLY.
I'LL TRY TO DO BETTER NEXT TIME.
THAT IS ALL I HAVE FOR RIGHT
NOW.
WE CAN'T DO THIS ALONE AND WE
OBVIOUSLY HAVEN'T.
AND WE --
>> DO YOU KNOW IF THE SUSPECT
WAS FOUND ON CAMPUS OR OFF
CAMPUS AT LEAST.
>> OR WHERE HE IS IN CUSTODY AT
THIS TIME OR WHO BROUGHT HIM
INTO CUSTODY.
>> WOULD YOU TELL YOU TO THE
BEST OF MY KNOWLEDGE HE WAS NOT
FOUND ON CAMPUS.
I DID NOT TELL YOU WHERE HE WAS
LOCATED OR WHERE HE WAS TAKEN
INTO CUSTODY OR WHERE HE IS
LOCATED NOW.
>> STATE POLICE TAKE HIM INTO
CUSTODY.
>> WE'LL HAVE MORE INFORMATION
ON THAT.
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH.
WE'LL HAVE MORE INFORMATION.
>> SO A MAJOR DEVELOPMENT.
YOU SAW JUST PLAYING OUT IN THE
MIDST OF THIS PRESS CONFERENCE.
THEY BEGIN OVER THE SHOOTING AT
UVA WITH THE POLICE AND THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNIVERSITY
CALLING FOR HELP AND ASSISTANCE
TO LOCATE THE SUSPECT AND THEN
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE PRESS
CONFERENCE THE CHIEF OF POLICE
RECEIVING WORD FROM HIS DEPUTY
THAT THE SUSPECT IS NOW IN
CUSTODY.
AS WE KNOW NOW THAT ALL OF THE
PEOPLE WHO WERE KILLED IN THIS
INCIDENT AND WOUNDED WERE
STUDENTS INVOLVED IN THIS MASS
SHOOTING AT UVA OVERNIGHT.
JON MILLER IS HERE WITH ME.
JON, IMPORTANT, THE SUSPECT IS
IN CUSTODY.
THEY ARE CLEARLY NOT PREPARED TO
GIVE MORE ON THAT BECAUSE THE
CLEAVE OF POLICE JUST FOUND IT
OUT IN THE MIDDLE OF THE PRESS
CONFERENCE.
BUT THERE IS A LOT THAT WE
LEARNED ABOUT PREVIOUS
INTERACTIONS AND WHAT HAPPEN AND
HOW THIS PLAYED OUT JUST NOW.
>> SO WHAT WE LEARNED IS THAT
THIS IS SOMEONE THAT WAS FLAGGED
AT UVA.
THIS IS A ADVANCED PROCESS WHERE
THEY HAVE PEOPLE FROM STUDENT
AFFAIRS, REPRESENTATIVES FROM
THE POLICE DEPARTMENT,
PSYCHOLOGISTS WHO ASSESS
THREATS, THE THREAT INVOLVED
SOMEBODY REPORTING CHRIS JONES
HAD MADE A STATEMENT THAT HE HAD
A GUN.
THEY INTERVIEWED HIS ROOMMATE
WOULD SAID HE HAD NEVER SEEN A
GUN.
THEY INTERVIEWED THE COMPLAINANT
WHO SAID THERE WAS NO THREAT
THAT CAME WITH THE IDEA THAT HE
MADE A STATEMENT ABOUT HAVING A
GUN.
BUT AS WE PEEL BACK THE LAYERS,
WE SEE HE ALSO SEEMS TO HAVE AN
ARREST OUTSIDE OF CAMPUS FOR AN
ILLEGAL WEAPON THE YEAR BEFORE.
SO, WE'RE STARTING TO PEEL BACK
THE LAYERS OF EARLY SIGNS THAT
THIS INDIVIDUAL WAS HEADED FOR
TROUBLE.
WHAT IS REMARKABLE TO ME IS THAT
ALL OF THIS CAME OUT IN THE
FIRST PRESS CONFERENCE.
IN OTHER WORDS, RATHER THAN WAIT
FOR TWO DAYS LATER, EARLY SIGNS
WERE MISSED, POLICE DID THIS OR
THAT, FOR TIM LONGO, THE KMCHIE
OF POLICE FOR UVA TO PUT THAT
OUT FRONT AND SAY I'M TELLING
YOU EVERYTHING THAT WE HAVE
RIGHT NOW IS A BIG DIFFERENCE
FROM WHAT WE SEE.
IT IS A HIGH LEVEL OF
TRANSPARENCY AND I THINK THEY
HAVE TO GET CREDIT FOR THAT.